dylan thank you so much for taking time
out of your social distancing
to chat about your new comic book series
sun eater
this is an original story with true
roots
how how are you describing sun eater
what's your elevator pitch that i know
you've got down
oh you know in truth i'm not the best
elevator
i i have adhd so i talk away until the
elevator doors open but you know
to simplify it and boil it down
i would say that sun eater is about a
drug
addict father who makes a deal with the
gods
sacrificing his own leg for this
otherworldly power
in order to save his son from the first
ever king of norway
historically really existed harold
fairhair
and his five guards so in doing so
what kind of results is a very dark and
bloody and
a little bit sexual story as well
given the nature of heavy metal which is
kind of a perfect union in this way
um that is you know a dark metaphor for
drug addiction and uh and also
how these things pass on to our children
so
that's the uh the the best elevator
pitch i can give you
uh hopefully it's a short elevator ride
you did a great job
thank you i haven't heard it's almost
like you've been working on this for
five years or something
um this project has really allowed you
to open up to your fans and and
really share a different side with them
that you haven't really opened up about
you've said that this main character
is kind of based off of your mom can you
speak a little bit to that
yeah and um you know i won't go into
too many details because i do feel like
the story actually speaks for itself in
a lot of these regards
um and i encourage people to read it if
they want to know more about this avenue
but i don't really
generally this is just me
i'm i don't talk about things and i
should probably
do better about this personally but i
don't really talk about stuff like this
unless i give myself a lot of time to
think about it and ruminate on it
right so she she my own mother
is influencing the main character
basically one for one in a lot of ways
besides it being
very obviously fantasy um
there is a lot of one for one so his
interactions with
other characters his compulsions his
his ability or inability to
kind of navigate in the world around him
is really all
informed by real life happenings that
i've encountered with my own mother
and i think in that way it uh you know
after posting the posts i did recently
and talking a little bit about the same
thing
i had a huge amount of comments not only
overwhelming support
but also people who are in similar
situations and grown up in similar
households and
and i found that really really nice um
and
you know what i hope for for sun eater
in general is that not only is it a
story that's
interesting and entertaining to people
who like this kind of genre
but also that it's a little bit of a
cautionary tale
and it's a little bit uh it empathizes
with people who are
raised in similar situations and that
creates a dialogue between all of us
yeah have you been able to share sun
eater with your family
already maybe shared it with your mom
i've shared it with my brother and my
father
definitely not my mother no um but
you know again since i've been writing
it for five years i've been talking
about it for quite some time
so uh my family oftentimes will do
readings especially my brother and i
right
so we've been doing readings of sun
eater over the years and
as i've continued to get more artwork
back and formulated a little more
a lot of the times these conversations
that we have about the subject matter
what fuels the next
episode or issue that i've been writing
so
it's been uh it's been a lot of talk and
a lot of refining
do you feel like sun eater put you
in a dark place or helped you emerge
from one or was a little bit of both
that's a good question um i think it's
definitely a little bit of both
i think in order to emerge out of it
with a more objective and clear mindset
i needed to dive into it
a little more and i think i was afraid
of doing that for a very long time
before i started writing sonia i was
kind of turning my eyes away from it
so that i didn't have to deal with it or
look it directly in the face
and when i did and i gave myself
a lot of time to to formulate my
thoughts on it
it uh it helped me come to peace with a
lot of it
and you know i finished writing for
example i finished
revising i should say the final episode
last week
so i'm still writing it and i still have
changes and
new things that i come to if it was up
to me
i'd probably be writing it the rest of
my life
i i just also know that it needs to get
out there at some point or another
i am so thrilled and excited about this
new project for you because you've been
working on this for
more than five years now um why
a comic book why have this be your next
avenue in your career
well yeah thank you um it's interesting
you know i started writing this
five years ago because i was kind of
in a place mentally where i felt like i
needed to get
some sort of story out for myself to
better understand the scenario that was
happening
and so i started writing something that
i just knew
i loved which was fantasy genre and i
thought that i could
kind of uh place the setting around
the idea in an interesting way so i
started writing it like that but i
actually
intended it to be live action um and
when i started writing it and intending
it to be live action i realized that it
was restricting me
from making it the way i envisioned it
because i was
in the back of my mind i was thinking
about things like budget and i was
thinking about
like how physically someone would even
do these things
um so i actually just changed gears
completely and i ended up writing it for
comics and for animation
um and i found that my thoughts were
much more free-flowing at that point
i was able to do things i wasn't able to
do before and
furthermore i felt like i was able to
more accurately
represent in a weird way what i was
hoping to get across with the concept
when you take a step back and you look
at it as a whole
which would you feel has it been more
challenging more rewarding like how are
you feeling about it as it's about to
come out to the world i quickly realized
that when i was writing it
that this story was only in part my own
right that i was writing this
not from a perspective of
you know what i what i think that
interaction was like
but really what i hoped that interaction
could have been
right and how i hoped that
in this way the main character kveldwolf
could have been or had the same amount
of
uh i guess dexterity and follow through
with their ideals that my mother didn't
have
so i think it has been challenging
yes but it's very cathartic yeah and the
only thing that i really hope
is that when people read this and if
they want to support which i hope that
they do and they
click the link after this and they end
up buying an issue
or getting the set i i hope that they
read it
and they read it for what it is which is
a
personal story that hopefully extends a
little greater
than that that it's cautionary
and that it says something about that
style
of writing it says something about that
experience
and they take away something from it and
if they don't that's okay
because i still was able to get it out
and hopefully grow from the story
and that's really all i i hope for it so
all in all
i think that it has been less
challenging more rewarding